you know when you grow up and there's
people that you look up to or that
you're a fan of I go through this [__]
all the time when I like meet somebody
um and I'm like I've been in situations
where I'm like I've hung out with like
all five members of Bone Thugs in
harmony at the same time and I'm like
man if you would have told me when I was
a little kid I'd be hanging out with
Bone Thugs That's so crazy have you had
one of those moments recently um D I
have those moments all the time like
when I run into people and they're like
yo you're killing it I love what you're
doing yeah I'll be like what like I I
just get flashbacks up when I was
watching them yeah but I've had that
moment my mom has had that moment like
what was the moment your mom had um okay
so when I was like really young she used
to play MC light all the time in the car
and so me and my sister we used to like
rap it and we used to rap it for my mom
and stuff and so like going from that
moment which was like years ago to like
now I was at I think the Rock Nation
brunch or something it was either that
one or some Oscar brunch but she was at
my table cuz they sign signed everybody
tables and like I had called my mom she
was talking to her and she was like dang
I would have never thought like somebody
she grew up listening to she would like
and then like I always talk to MC like
she like tell your mom I say hi so it
always like history like that that's
sick shout out to MC light the legend
yeah that's incredible um when is I know
you just put the artwork up but when is
the project dropping um we don't have a
date yet but it's coming very soon so I
like the artwork I like yeah is there uh
for you right now like who would you say
is like your next like if you could
shine a light on an artist that you're a
fan of that's like just on the come up
just starting out somebody who you you
know obviously you took you took my on
the road with you but is there anybody
who you think deserves like some
recognition somebody who you know is
killing it oh it's this one girl um dang
I feel bad I forgot the
name H I got to get her name cuz I I
this this one girl she's like a rapper
I've been seeing her a lot like on Tik
Tok but I think she's like on the come
up right now I I forgot her name but
it's like this light-skinned girl I mean
that's so like so many lik people but
yeah I don't know her name but if I had
to name another person
I don't know like a lot of them are
already like lit like doing their thing
yeah like it's hard for me to find new
artists there's so many dope rappers on
Tik Tok that like if you scroll like
you'll be like oh this like I feel like
we be finding new artists to come up
here and rap just off of Tik Tok
sometimes cuz you'll be like oh this
[__] this dude this dude's ill yeah I'll
be I'll be more so like watching artists
who I feel like really got that like cuz
I'm good at that like when I first even
before like I was taking music series I
could predict when a person was like
going to get famous like even before
they had like a lot of followers I would
see them and it would always be right
and I had nothing to show for it I'm
like bro I found an artist like be anr
have a label would you ever want to have
a label probably one day you can sign
artist yeah but I would probably wait
till I'm like really established cuz I
don't want to play with no no yeah yeah
that's the one thing like you said
that's important cuz a lot of people
just want to have a label cuz they feel
like it's the thing to do when you make
it yeah it's like you're kind of playing
with people's lives low key yeah so so
it's like you don't want to be in that
position like you got to get your [__]
to where you're like I can chill a
little bit cuz it's a human being like
you know and even if they're with you
for two years it's like I don't want to
waste two years of your prime your yeah
for sure if if I'm not going to do right
by it so that's dope well look you're on
tour you got uh I think your next tour
dat is in Denver yep I think it is
Denver you smoke a weed all the time
nice yeah nice so if you got some I got
some drugs for you do you do shrooms no
no never do the shrooms we got to change
that we got to give him a shot oh no but
do them at home okay at the
crib theer pressure for me just play
some music like some like Erica Badu
Erica do throw on like just a cool
playlist you giving me Gemini Vibes
what's your son I am um you know what's
funny is I'm not into I'm an aquarius I
almost said I'm on a qu which is the
name it's the name of that Outcast album
right there um but no I am a uh I was
born in January okay I was born in
January too I'm the
27th okay I'm the 20 I mean I'm not the
20 anything I'm the ninth so are you
Aquarius no I don't know when the cut
off but I'm very kind of similar cuz
what's the cut off when's Aquarius
season start and end I don't know I
think it's like at the end of January
but so what are you then I'm a Capricorn
see I don't know about any of this where
it do you believe in this stuff yeah
okay I just see to me that kind of like
like the uh horoscope scope thing mhm
like is it accurate like I
mean we don't have to go down that
rabbit hole but I'm just curious like
like have you met somebody and been like
you're not C like like compatible cuz I
know people who won't date somebody if
they're not if they're in like some
range of like when were you born ah we
ain't going to work yeah are you one of
them it's like yeah I'm one of them oh
wow I mean I don't be doing that like
I'm not going to lie to you I don't be
like oh if you're this like I don't
really so what what's your like in
incompatible sign according to you know
uh the horoscope books that people read
probably um
probably Aries an Aries I don't know
when is that I think that's like March
so if you're born in March don't even
call no it could be two things though
yeah cuz like it ain't it don't end like
some of them be starting like in the
middle she was born in January and she
and she's AR Capricorn sorry she's
Capricorn I was born in January and I'm
Aquarius Aquarius so I could Aquarius
yeah Pisces mm so basically Aquarius AR
yeah but I think you get along with
Aries Aquarius but aquariuses y'all are
like very
like rebellious y are very rebellious
y'all try to like not follow the rules
y'all are very different have your own
mind very
what's the
word so far you're spot on yeah like
aquariuses are the type to invent things
y are very much Geniuses like I'll take
all of these compliments I'll give you a
I'll give you a whole an analysis of it
like one time I went to New York and I
guess people sign on the street and I
got it right really mhm and at video
shoots I'll be doing that too and they
be like so shocked um Libras are crazy
people why you say that I just that's
something I I know to be true really
yeah yeah yeah yeah I've had my uh he
had are stting Libras are psychopath so
shout out to my uh hopefully you know my
kids are Libra now so hopefully he
doesn't grow up to be some toxic
[__] shout out to the Libras